wow
yeah that's hot
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by courtney cox she's
an actress and director you know from
gargantuan hits including friends scream
cougar town and many more she recently
launched her very own home beauty brand
called home court so be on lookout for
that and she also stars alongside greg
kinnear in the new comedy horror series
shining veil which is set to premiere on
stars march 6th courtney cox welcome to
the show thank you i've been following
along as you've been sharing your
kitchen adventures over the last couple
years how are you around spicy food um i
don't
do spicy food until right now
i really don't i don't first i'm really
savory i mean i'm really savory no i
love salt but i don't do spice
what are we gonna eat it right now yep
that's how it goes
what's
some
good
not much that's right
[Music]
it's really good
okay
so in your latest project shining bill
you played the role of patricia phelps a
mother who moves her dysfunctional
family away from the chaos of city
living in brooklyn and towards this
creepy haunted mansion in the country
and showrunner jeff astroff recently
said in an interview that you called him
to tell him this script is the only
thing that's ever been written for me
what was it about the character that
gave you such a strong gravitational
pull towards the project okay first of
all is there something behind me that
you're reading because who can do that
i couldn't tell you that much
information about the show
ever that was incredible oh well as an
actress i i take that as such a
compliment thank you so much there's got
to be something behind me okay um
she's so layered she's going through a
midlife crisis she just had an affair
with the handyman and her marriage is
not doing great she is
at that age where you know things change
um
she's got a teenage daughter which
that's never easy
and uh she's dealing with some mental
issues at least her family thinks she is
but she's actually really depressed so i
just it's it's a it's a 30-minute show
that
i can go from being really sarcastic
depressed to emotional and crying so
i've never done something that had that
many things to play
[Music]
oh this one's definitely how many is
this on the scale
i mean am i why am i going in for more
maybe you'll like it
you know you're selling yourself short
on hot sauce maybe you're just into it
that's too much skin i don't need any
more i mean well if you need if you're
making me i would but
god i haven't had a wing in a long time
the wings are good there we go hitting
forgot what you were missing
all right that's good
so recently you launched a home product
line home court which is a line of soaps
candles and signature fragrances what
would you say is the biggest mistake
that hopeless bro dude bachelors like
myself make when they go candle shopping
i would say just the sense so that you
guys buy
i mean
it's not okay
um and the vessel you it really matters
if you're gonna put something on your
table it has to smell good but it has to
look good and sometimes i'll get candles
from people and although
i can't even leave it on the table in
order i don't care what it smells like
so i did make a candle that is coming
out soon and it's really it's the vessel
is beautiful you can reuse it if you
want as a pencil holder or tea cup or
something to wash down your hot spices
[Music]
all right
i'm good
i don't want to act like i'm so
got this down because i don't but i
couldn't handle it
could have fooled me
my lips are getting a little swollen but
that's okay
is it true that the party scene at the
end of scream took 21 days to shoot and
was such an arduous experience that the
crew had shirts made that said i
survived scene 118.
oh god that was the ending in the whole
thing that was intense yeah
um
oh yeah and it's hard you do all those
stunts and you have blood and it's
sticky and
anyway yes it's it's really hard to do
the finales of these it's so intense and
i remember being younger doing that and
i i was doing all my stunts it was no
big deal and i thought i could do it
again and i did
but i was paying for it yeah well that
last scene is 42 minutes just by itself
like that last location once you're in
the the last place you're gonna die or
not die in yeah
is it true that you lobbied for the role
of gayle weathers because you wanted
like a nasty character to counter your
nice friend's image yeah
because i'm so used to playing i mean i
was on family ties and i was sweet
lauren miller and i was on friends but i
had to prove that i could be really yeah
did like wes craven think oh this is
nice friends is she gonna have the edge
for gail exactly the edge is a good word
all right courtney are you ready to move
on here to the next wing
this is the angry phoenix here in the
four spot and you are doing great you're
doing great i'm okay
how is am i gonna make it through this
one oh yeah okay you're good all right
oh god
[Music]
it's a tough wing it is i want to know
what's the point i mean
i mean seriously i mean there is some
flavor but
do people just enjoy them
the the masochism of it all or well it's
funny like i've gone to hot sauce expos
before in the past
and they do look like the parking lot of
a slayer concert kind of you know like
the people watching it there is just uh
it's amazing a part of the hot sauce
subculture i do think is just sort of
chasing that like extreme nature of it
all right yeah because it just sticks
with you
stop seeing you cooking everything from
jamie oliver's chicken and milk to then
serving laura dern your recipe for the
world's greatest turkey burgers
what is an alabama sushi roll and can
you talk me through how to make one
so alabama sushi is
um
turkey you can get it at ralph's it's
just like honey maple jerky and you put
french's mustard
mayonnaise
then you put a little bit of bavarian
cheese on it sometimes i put avocado if
i want to go really healthy
i have to have a crunch so i put fritos
and then you roll it up really nicely
and that's how you would love it i'm
already down if you're eating this kind
of stuff i mean you should see what we
have in post i'm gonna give camera guy
bill the whole thing he's gonna hands
and pans this thing bring it to life and
then you know what i'm gonna take that
recipe back to my kitchen and try it out
myself i think you should all right
courtney are you ready to move on here
to the halfway point okay my my lips are
burning i'm just saying
okay
[Music]
hello scalientes that means hot
i liked it better than the last one
yep no no i haven't seen the kickback
yet but i liked it oh yeah
but on first impression
oh it's really good
two of my favorites
wow
and not to lead the witness but those
are the two we make really
um it kinda has a little bit of a
sweetness to it oh it's starting to burn
yeah oh it's like i'd like to take that
compliment and pull it back a little bit
i'm still going to go with it that
doesn't help oh yeah yeah okay oh i
can't wait to get to pucker butt all
right
all right courtney well in the meantime
we have a recurring segment on our show
called explain that graham where we do a
deep dive on our guest instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
contact so we'll pull the picture up
over here on the monitor you just tell
us the bigger story your instagram
sidenote rocks by the way thank you okay
my nose is running that's for sure all
right let's see what do you want to know
about the ground so
how big a thrill was it for you to play
tony danza alongside ed sheeran brandi
carlisle and elton john
i can't tell you what a thrill that was
i i love elton john so much
and ed was staying at my house and he
said is it okay if elton comes over for
dinner and i was like
duh
and i directed brandy's video um right
on time so i knew her
she's i'm really comfortable in her i
love her and i've known ed for years but
when he came and he said would you mind
doing this thing for instagram for
you know playing hold me closer tony
danza but it's actually only closer
young tony danza
which lisa codrow
it very clear after
look at my like we're hugging i mean you
can't get better than that but he was
sitting next to me and i was so nervous
i just learned the song about 20 minutes
before he came over my piano teacher i
was like come over now and then he left
and saw elton on the way out we're not
practicing anything um anyway so i was
playing and he was holding my arm
and i was going to get to that part
where you go
and i thought i'll never be able to do
this i can't even move my arm and i just
want to stay like this and i'm so scared
who's the nicest person
so nice
and this is like why this segment exists
you have a lasting memory from dinner
with michael jordan it's like a royalty
over here right he is such a great guy i
just remember this was so many years ago
this is early on my gram experience
um
i just uh i met him i forgot where we
were and he was wearing that beautiful
blue suit and he just was great he was
really personable and i i i think you
could see those eyes i was looking at
him kind of just in awe i mean i'd love
his as a big bulls fan well you know
what i'm from chicago so big uh big
jordan fan on this side you know yeah
and uh yeah you're from evanston i whoa
and your last name was evan so crazy is
it your talent
you're on the wikipedia a car over here
or something yeah listen
i'm not the only one researching today
yeah that's right
all right courtney are you ready to move
on here to the back half you're doing
great by the way
this is the queen majesty coco ghost
i will say i think it was um
dawson
is the one who got my lips burning and
keeping them feeling this way well in
the back half here there'll be a whole
new cast of characters bringing their
own okay
their own games to the party you ready
uh-huh okay
[Music]
oh yeah that catches up
okay
yep i feel that one for sure
i'm kind of excited that i can actually
go to a restaurant and
if they say
you want hot sauce i'm gonna say yeah
an eye-opening and awakening experience
here today
so in the past we've talked to guests
about juggling being an actor and
director simultaneously but then you've
also done things like finance films like
just before i go and i'm just curious
what do you learn about making a movie
when you're also the one cutting the
check to bring it to life
when you do pay for a movie which is
really dumb
um it's nice because no one can tell you
what to do so you're only making your
own mistakes and that's
feels better to me than making i mean
people making mistakes for me
but i love directing i love when i
directed cougar town i did about 10
episodes i just love it i'm very visual
what's the best lesson you learned about
scoring from gus van zandt
oh right god that was cool that i got to
how did you know
wow um yeah i sent him the film and he
was really nice and
he gave me advice i think he even said
something like trying to tie in the tone
of the movie because
a lot of times you want to play against
the tone of the film and uh
and by doing a different kind of
score
i'm just watching you you might be uh is
it hotter for you than it is for me
whoa
you know what um it might be you know i
think people think cause i've done this
so much that i'm just like some sort of
like uh i'm impervious to hot sauce
right like i can't be stopped with hot
sauce but my lips burn are they burning
right now yeah okay good i put put my
legs on one put my legs on put my pants
on one leg at a time you can't talk
either
okay
[Music]
okay
i like the one oh yeah oh
i like that i was gonna say
i like the way it starts off a little
sweet yeah
has that barbecue sort of vibe to it
like a good barbecue sauce and then
afterwards right
it kicks into a whole nother gear it
really does
but it's kind of good and yet i hate it
let's see
going in salute
yeah
mom's got some kick
do you feel like misfits of science and
then your role as a telekinetic teenager
do you feel like that's maybe been
overlooked by the superhero enthusiasm
that's swept over hollywood over the
last 15 years
oh my god
you just do my i really thought this was
gonna be
a big post for the gram
i did this thing with this picture we're
all in our costume misfits of science
and i always tell the kinetic and there
was the guy who was really tall and then
there's uh dean paul martin was oh he
was just trying to help us he was like
this professor or whatever but
then there was the guy who had electric
thing yeah and he ran faster than the
speed of light or
anyway i did a little thing where i was
like i'm surprised marvel didn't pick
this one
no one thought it was funny but me but
um
did you have to raise my mic because i
feel like i'm yelling oh
you know what i do do we touch these
probably not these just kind of stay in
a in a nice position yeah like if the
equilibrium is off and if the world's
moving
it's probably more
because of the hot sauces yeah
[Music]
and speaking of
are you ready to move on to the next one
this is the bomb beyond insanity okay
the mom
all right
[Music]
did you make this one
so you can say whatever you want
horrible i'm sorry
no no it's not horrible it's just just
hot yeah there's no
flavoring after no there's no redeeming
quality there's no culinary quality
just pure heat yeah that's just heat and
then it just doesn't stop
this is gross oh my god that's the war
sorry to bomb
i mean maybe it's great for some
wow
that's hot
oh [ __ ]
i can't wait to get to pucker but
did you have a favorite or most
memorable cameo
from the monica love interest between
tom selleck
george clooney john favreau and
jean-claude van damme it's quite a
roster
oh
okay the tear is just a reflection
okay um
well tom selleck was the nicest
only the tallest
[Music]
john favreau is the best director
he wasn't directing that
how would you quantify the impact of
shooting in front of a lot from me
crying i know
i know i know and i'm right here with
you i'm right here with you courtney all
right how would you quantify the impact
of shooting in front of a live studio
audience you know i read i saw an
interview with executive producer kevin
bright where he talked about how writers
like if a joke didn't hit in the live
studio audience writers would workshop
and rewrite the rewrite the rewrite the
jokes
in real time
me too i'm right here with you i'm ready
um
yeah these
these writers
were so incredible that
when we were taping the show the reason
why friday nights would take so
there was no high voice it was good or
there was no it's okay it had to be the
best and that was what made the show so
good our writers were so incredible
oh
okay
i'm sorry no it's uh it's good put an
asmr effect on it
oh yeah
okay i'm gonna put this back but it's
mine yeah
don't take a sip of this sure whatever
happens over there
this day's over here
okay
ah
i just don't know how my lips gonna get
hotter
we'll find out
oh poker butt let's do this
are you doing it yeah extra mean green
okay
[Music]
who can feel anything after the boss
right i think like if there's anything
that's nice about the bomb does it just
leave scorched earth throughout your
mouth
and then all of a sudden oh god this one
gets you back in the throat
yeah
that one has some tricks yeah
i'm just like i'm in such pain it
doesn't matter what's happening right
and you know what i mean
there we go there we go
i mean why not
[ __ ] it
i feel like i'm gonna live in the woods
now just like
so i was i was really tickled to hear
that you and ed sheeran your close
friends that you even let him crash at
your malibu pad while he was doing his
album multiply how would you rate him as
a houseguest like you didn't let him
bring benny blanco over did you i know i
do know benny blanco but i know i don't
know if benny ever came to the house um
ed is that it's a good houseguest
[Music]
there's some after effect
i'll poke her butt
okay
um ed does like to
talk to alexa at the house
um and
he uh likes to order get mess
just randomly amazon and i'll get a gift
mask i must have eight
but um ed is really funny and he's a
great guy
i hate this milk so much but you know
what any port in a storm you know
i mean for my coffee i use uh this is
like half and half
although they did say because i did some
research what should you do of course
you did
i'm not even a nerd like that
but
um
you eat butter or salt or a like a lot
of saturated fat well
if you say courtney cox then it's the
truth
what are you doing
[Music]
i saw as he didn't just do a dab he
dunked it oh he did
okay the last remember to really take
that word dab seriously there you go
yeah that was good that's good right i'm
not gonna
dunk it i'm just gonna dab it
just dab it that's all that's you know
okay
all right
cheers cheers courtney
[Music]
what is that on this goal scale
2
million i was out to dinner and i um
preparing myself for this
i just tried this hot sausage on the
table and i said oh
i got this
and i said to my friend what is this he
goes let me check the scoville scale
it was 2 000.
[Music]
i was so excited yeah you probably had
some crystal or like some frank's red
hot or something like this and it wasn't
even that spicy but look at you today
yeah taking down the gauntlet and you
know what the good news here no more
wings to go i do want to close things
out with a somewhat prosaic question but
i am really interested in how you think
about the continued and historic success
of the friends franchise like
dom our producer for example
she has an almost sacred relationship
with the show she can quote every single
episode she goes to trivia nights she
had the best birthday of her life at the
friends experience and even one time
after somebody in our crew got married
she changed the last name to everybody
on our closing credits which was like a
tip to that one after vegas friends
episode why do you think the show has
continued to bank so much cultural
currency even as it approaches two
decades of being off air
the reason why i think it's
gone on and on and on is because
humor is humor and when you're in your
30s and you're going through life and
the characters are so distinct from each
other
i think that everyone can experience
that part of their life
i just think the writing was so
incredible and the chemistry is
incredible and
every now and then there's like a little
pepper that gets swallowed it reminds
you
it just i think they're all the
characters are relatable in some way
you're either
you know a flighty person or you're
a sarcastic person or
a neat freak
no matter who you are you find someone
you can relate to and look at you
courtney cox taking on the wings of
death didn't have much confidence in
yourself going in but absolutely crushed
the gauntlet and now there's nothing
left to do but roll out the red carpet
for you this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life um okay so i just
had a show come out called shining veil
it's on stars
it's really good and it's scary and
funny
i have a product line called home court
which is essentially beauty products for
the home they smell incredible and they
really work
okay that's it guys
[Music]
[Applause]
great job thank you
are you happy you did it now that you're
on the other side i would do it again
i for sure i loved it
i loved it because you're fun too
and you can actually like just cry if
you have to
for the first time ever
hot sauce for kids that's right hot
sauce for kids i'd like to introduce you
to hot ones junior the green
this sauce is a super tasty flavor clash
of green apples sweet banana warm
jalapeno lets kids sort of experience
the hot ones tradition but at the
foothills of mount scoville
heatness.com.com to get your hands on
the green hot ones junior before anyone
else
it's super tasty and it's a hot sauce
for kids